it's disgusting
yeah look at the vast landscape of oh
this is good right now it's all
beautiful ah there's a double rainbow
horrible you look good hi though see
that that's why we don't come up places
like this because you can fall don't
laugh
how you doing papa check never again
yo style yo beauty Oh smiles guys you
and I look like twins
we're both tired I think we're the we're
the palest ones here I am so scared of
the hide coming up here so the scary man
there's a pterodactyl nest around here I
can tell sometimes you have to ask
yourself don't complain because if you
complain you die and when you die then
you can complain but tell your mother
secret to life man hold on the make it
better it is nothing free engaging as we
love yes in the staff
today I came up the box I look at your
shoes Mexican oh it's you can feel the
fire girl is blazing lately I'm feeling
kind of crazy we are over here head
Zippy's about to get our grub on where I
got my foot leg but what do you guys
think about zippy
oh my god so long it's okay so to me if
you guys don't know is it because it
means is kind of like Hawaiian Denny's
to me every time I come to Oahu I always
got to eat here so I'm not gonna be this
loco moco love for eat that doughnut you
a question oh so what's the key to a
successful relationship I don't have
what is the key to a successful
relationship what is a successful a
relationship though yeah is it a happy
one
or is it we learn to cope you confucius
mom what's your definition of a
successful relationship you know like
when you wake up and sometimes like you
wanna freakin throw and it's not that no
you want to know steps I can say okay
yeah so there's this honesty
communication are the two main yeah as
long as you're honest and love you
communicate there will be happiness
so there's no other reason for you to be
what if what if one day what if one day
you get really really fat in the case he
looks at you hey you know what you're
fat how would you feel about that how
are you gonna Soviet I'm [ __ ] here how
many times have I been to night
Oh David started this theme of what
makes a what's the key to a successful
religion yes because we have a lot of
couples here and it seems that everybody
seems so happy a successful relationship
you said thank you
it starts off with what the three
staying like I love hate like love hate
what stage are you in right now hey mega
we got it from the veterans and they
said you have to forgive everything I do
thank you for universal together cameras
running out of batteries guys
come to me
well you have bunches you tell them
about 4,000 miles to our swimming point
I never knew that we had to swim and
walk to our destination but that's cool
whatever guess the question why do I
complain so much
s myself so interesting story we were we
are again Alan Davis we are at Alan
Davis and Alan Davis has this this plank
in which everybody jumps off of
apparently it's like the funnest thing
to do here I decided that I could do it
myself
right and you know what [ __ ] it's not
that funny ha ha it was funnier because
he was being loud there was a bunch of
people we don't even own you ha and then
we don't have it and so I try to do this
double jump thing where you where you
get that first trip to give you that
little bouncing on pain but you do that
one bounce and the second bounce is
supposed to propel you but what happened
is well what happened was I slipped I
did a Billy Bob on my face straight into
the water
it's not that funny
it's pretty funny man if he saw to your
face but the but the fish was pretty